hello
hello
are we live
are we alive
[Music]
hello hello
hello
we are live let's go
you guys still hear me okay
i got a pop filter for my mic and
hopefully it works for one and doesn't
make me uh
unhearable i guess
who knows with
streaming technology
welcome good morning
good afternoon good evening
is it crisp
hopefully not as bad of hopping sounds
my fair maiden
i am no maiden
i can be if you want to though
sounds magnificent awesome
good to hear
welcome
so this is probably
going to be the longest stream i've done
now i don't know how long that's gonna
be
but
i i plan to do a lot today that that is
the plan to do
a lot
i've got the uh wait a minute i hope
this is on cordless because that'll make
everything easier hopefully this works
still actually hold on
hold
it does perfect
perfect okay
not 24 hours i'm just saying like more
than three hours like they usually do no
that looks bad doesn't it whoa
hold up fam
why is it that
see it's all free me now yeah
see this is why
we can't do that
you gotta do this
see now that looks crisp right
that looks good
[Music]
hey there we go
which part of the game are you at i'm
not really sure
i am not really sure
we're through it though i'd say we're
like halfway done maybe a little bit
less
yep full screen is fire
yeah now we're good okay but i plan on
doing a lot today
i've got the list pulled up which is
going to be slightly more annoying to
pull up actually since we're in full
screen it'll do the no signal thing and
then show us what we want without any
sound which is kind of poo poo dong
water
but if you want to follow along on this
list you can
uh for every boss i'm thinking that
i'm i'm pretty sure
we can do every quest line
every main boss
and we can always come back to all of
these bosses so i kind of want to do all
the quest lines we can
in all of the main bosses
and then we will go back and just do
every single little boss in the game
millennia first try today yeah i think
first order of business
which i believe we've gone yeah we've
gone all through the city already
is
well we already beat reichardt so we're
good on that reichardt is dead
have we talked to tanith yet i don't
think so
i don't think so
yep there she is
being a goober oh
you allow me some time
our lord's carcass is vast
and not easily consumed is she really
gonna eat this entire thing
please
find oh no we're gonna do soldier of
godric through the entire
um
is
it doesn't look like anyone's in volcano
manor still
it's gluten
that's a lot of gluten
oh
what do we got here
tonic of forgetfulness so that's for
ryan's quest line
which i believe we can continue doing
um that's not our room is it i think
this is her room
oh she's not here
is she already down below
i think so
glemmious fury
we already beat uh
our boy
prison town church
temple of igle we did we did do that
let's see if we can go find raya real
quick
you can also give it to the guy
following the gold mask really
oh do you guys want to do that instead
i'll let you guys choose a lot of this
stuff because i know a lot of it like
uh
you have to do one or the other you
can't do it in one place you're pretty
much
welcome subzero you're never late if
you're here
i love when people say sorry i'm late
like you're required to be here what are
you at work
guys everyone put epson chat for kyle
who was hyping up battlefield 2042
you can either give him an f or an
lol
i think lol is uh is better honestly
i told you that game was gonna suck kyle
i did
i told you that
i said that game's gonna suck and you
were like no it's gonna be good bro
it's gonna be a good game
it's battlefield
i'm like exactly it's battlefield
yeah you wanted it to be great
it wasn't though
it's one of the worst games in recent
memory right
where is
my blood
we're heavy boys
it was hot garbage
awful
i didn't even play it and i knew it was
bad
oh a somber five we'll take it
where is raya
she should be right here
where did she go before this i don't
remember
you literally just fell asleep
are you from not america where it's ken
that scared me
she should be i know did we miss
something
yeah you can backstep through lava i
just didn't
because i'm cringe i guess
did i miss our chance to do it
yeah i spoke with their serpent form
what
cool dude
[Music]
yeah don't i give it to her over there
i just need to find her where is she
no we don't need to reset the area
that's some weak [ __ ]
she should be here
tanith is eating reichardt right now
no i would not smash
raya or the serpent form
are you all horny already
we just started
she goes nowhere else well clearly she
goes somewhere else
i miss it if i kill reichardt poop
well let's give it to corwin then can we
do that
oren
or win
let's give it to him
i don't know why i don't like him i just
i don't like corwin i don't like him
maybe i'm a douchebag for that i have no
idea
there is no try there is only do
it doesn't do anything to him
i didn't even know you could give it to
him someone just said it in chat that's
it
[Music]
i killed r well i would imagine you can
continue her questline
because they give you the forgetfulness
vibe vial
because they're chilling over there
his arms are both out
that's cool why do they not give you a
place
to reload over here kind of weird
or a side of grace that's what i mean
try fortnite
no you
yeah i guess you can't go up there
you can offer to him it gave me the
option to but i chose not to
okay what do you guys want to do because
i can just i i'm assuming ray is
somewhere
and we can look it up
[Music]
because i've done the raya one
i'm not playing that pay to win game
diablo immortal
ew
once you kill reichardt it's over she's
gone
yeah but why do we know that for sure
are we just saying that
epic
fortnite
she just bales
[Music]
yeah we're gonna do as best we can
plasma
[Music]
okay now we're just talking about pay to
win and not being helpful
[Music]
i'm gonna go give it to him if we can't
give it to ryan then i'm just gonna give
it to him because i don't know where she
goes
other than there
cat what's a better game apex or
fortnite
or are they both bad
if you offer it to the weirdo he will
refuse it
that's what i like to see i've seen a
lot of apex
apex is awesome
[Music]
eldon ring is the right answer
all right overwatch or overwatch 2.
ah you appear to be doing well how do
you know that
well then
would you like to learn an incantation
uh doesn't look like i can give it to
him yet
he needs to go to uh
we give it to him
nope
i think we have to go to the
mountaintops now
i think we really do actually
we've done almost everything we can
at this point
who's here
or spanning great bridge oh we can go
battle worm face in here
let's just make a decision we can always
come back and do that but let's go uh
let's move on
you can give it to him afterwards
oh okay yeah yeah like when he's
groveling
when he realizes that everything's a lie
[Music]
make him forget there
by the way that's a way easier way to
get in here
i hate these streams because they end
that's good
the mass effect series
i was gonna say mine is saying drama i
hope
[Music]
nerd
ooh another thing i should ask is should
we go get the mimic here or no
we could have two
godricks
i think we should that'll help
get out of here with that weak [ __ ]
be a man
but imagine two of us
the gargoyles are the dragons
uh i hate the birds
i think that's the right answer the
birds
this is the swallowhander zilehander
however you say it
[Music]
nah this is what we're using dog
is our weapon
bye
i hope you follow
wow good attack
good try
oh dude the death right birds are the
worst bro
they're so awful i think they're my
least favorite thing to fight in the
game i would say that yeah
also why can we not
ride torrent here
anybody know
because it kind of sucks that we can't
yo what up bro
because the game is bad that's the only
answer isn't there
did you do the sewer stuff we did most
of it
uh we haven't gone deep deep
we haven't gone deep in the butt of the
sewers
nerd
wow these guys are big
yeah
oh we get to save the horse
run horsey
run away
good horsey
can i ride you please
stay
oh i've never seen this before what the
heck
stop it
let me ride you
please
fine
whoa whoa whoa chill
i'm not killing the horse
i just think it's cool that it's alive
honestly
this one gets bigger
ow
gideon you [ __ ]
there we go
it's honestly just chilling now
ah that's cool
can i ride you please me trying to get a
girl
yeah it doesn't seem to work does it
is more god's great rune good isn't it
just hp increase
i should go down here first
where's that little uh room though is it
here
nah i missed it
we'll go here first
dodricks is good
i mean they're all good in their own way
it's a lot of hp
yeah
eventually that technique could work
all right you guys tell me
when that works and i'll give it a shot
because i really don't think it will
oh the room's just right there okay
officials retir attire what does this
read
out of curiosity
officials retired grill
rub rubbly grubby blue robe worn by
industrial officials who carry out their
grim tasks surveillance executions
gruesome rituals
the darkest duties drive the wheels of
mankind
feet
this is where we find melano's blade
the blade of pauline
this weird room
light it up a little bit
[Music]
hmm
yeah that's mel in his blade
what's up salmon
i don't think that's what those people
wear i think it's a different attire
anyone else find elden rings scary
i think elden ring is scary actually
okay now i need now we need to pick what
we want to do do we want to go deep all
right i'm gonna let you guys pick deep
in the sewers that's one
we could go and fight the fel omens over
here
or we can venture on
to the mountaintops of the giants
yeah they're all kind of scary to be
honest bbh
i think we should do fel omen then
sewers then forbidden
that would make the most sense
yeah let's read the blade
slate of calling dagger given to the one
who set out on a journey to fulfill her
duty long ago the power of its former
owner the kindling maiden is still
apparent the one who walks alongside
flame shall one day meet the road of
death and death
so it's melon is played
seriously torture sewers is easy
if you know where you're going
let's fight the fellowman though
wait
going the wrong way
i was like there should be a dude right
here
yeah scary [ __ ] up scary is is
probably the best way to put it yeah
probably
what is this guy doing here
one guy
is there a way to avoid this
nope
well here he is
wait is that
that's an interesting attack you have
probably should have healed there
[Music]
let me be
stacked
i get disoriented in here because it's
just all black
wouldn't let me do it
don't yell at me
[Music]
there we go
whoops
let's do this
oh wow just powering through that one
huh
oh my gosh
run
easy peasy
yeah what was the boss fight in dark
souls one called the four kings that
reminds me of this
i think it was four kings
easy peasy
this weapon is actually really good
this is my first time using it
[Music]
can you even crit these guys yup
answer that immediately by critting them
you didn't know this existed
you just never went to this tower i
guess
this is the zile hander zile winder
zile forehead
that's what it's called i guess
nice i think i can level now
should we go man i kind of want to go up
here and get
both great runes at the same time
let's do that it sounds like
cooler
let's go to the sewers
go deep in deep into the sewers
we should
probably we should probably check on
dung eater as well
you get it from the radon vegetable no
that's the ruin ruined greatsword right
ruin
something along those lines
[Music]
you lost 500 000 souls in dark souls 3
nice we're gonna have to play that game
again
rob never played it on stream but i
would like to that would be fun i could
probably beat dark souls 3 in a day
or less
the old wizard dude i mean jiren
if jaron's dead
we killed him
in uh selen's questline
i like how the hands are gone now it's
kind of weird
how are we doing dong eater
curse you golden order
one day
have a good one plasma
you'll get what's coming
all right lovely good talk
hey chat decided to kill jaron i didn't
blame chat they're all simps
if a girl's involved they choose the
girl
how long you streaming for until i'm
done
so a while
throw this on
[Music]
oh i don't need to do this i've already
done this
[Music]
i'm silly stupid
nice
i love fighting rats
lovely okay
me a simp
don't you dare hey you're the you guys
are the ones that voted
okay
you all voted
can't deny that
i hate these imps bro
leave me be
put a light a little light on the
subject
[Music]
ow
pain
it's like i know what i'm doing
you didn't vote well most of you did
okay
isn't it this way i don't remember
oh
close one actually we want to go down
here
[Music]
that's right
yo what up glenn how you doing man
we already done this stay over there let
me go
oh that's bad
at least we can heal on this now
you're going the wrong way
you're
right you're literally in the same room
but on the ground you're literally there
how did you not know that
what the [ __ ]
exactly i just get confused when i'm
here
[Music]
this is not where we want to go
now i'm confused
whoa
no that is my soyboy sound
well
my bad
i fell
[Music]
whoops bro maybe if you didn't go the
wrong way you wouldn't have fell
i know where i'm going
i should be the streamer
[Music]
dude
these things do a ridiculous amount of
damage
don't make fun of me like that
okay i'm sorry
sharp left
rat
dead
rat is this the hole we want to go down
[Music]
we're fine
oh that's what we needed
really
i guess i'm doing that to you as well
this has got to be an invisible wall
right
smell my butthole
it should be
i know where i am now
roderick is the best girl
yeah
can we not fight i'm not killing the
pots i love the pots
why
oh
oh no
no
hot boy
oh oof
oh my god get owned
i did not cause that
i i did not do that
what the heck just happened
oh someone clipped that can you clip on
youtube i have no idea
oh my god
i have to repent
okay it wasn't alexander though it was
some forehead
this is a spirit of moog yes
or a manifestation of moog
it's mogan time
see how well we do here
it's not his younger brother
that entrance is really cool
not doing a ton of damage
really
oh god
[Music]
ow damn
not a good idea
[Music]
it seems counter
to his character doesn't it
[Music]
ah come on
wow
that reaches insane
we might want to upgrade our weapon here
folks
[Music]
[Music]
that still hit me huh
i thought it was safe behind the pillar
i wasn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on man
[Music]
how do you dodge that
[Music]
oh the pillar got my eyesight
oh my god relentless
yeah let's go upgrade some stuff what do
you guys think because i feel like i'm
not doing enough
damage not doing enough damage here
let's go see what we can do
because he's big
he's strong bro he's strong
here at my feelings
i should probably upgrade a lot of
things but
we're letting that happen naturally okay
hey guys
okay so i need one and i have six but i
need one so that's right okay what do we
got here
okay let's sell that
um
man i'm never gonna use these so pop
those out
okay we got plenty strength
oh wait i need six and i have one
oh
i just tried to do it anyway like am i
dumb okay
knee heel
big do you ship moog and mikola
i don't know what that means
what is shipping
i feel like the shipping cost would be
expensive
what do you say
you
what is it
gideon sucks where should i go if you're
heading to the forge of the flame of
ruin in the snowy mountaintops of the
giants
you'll need to find the ground lift
you don't know shipping characters
tipping equals new gen equals dating
why don't you say dating
just say
that are you guys talking about
[Music]
huh
um
did we go to yeah we did go to
reichardt's no wait i'm in the wrong
spot we gotta go here
oh we did
what's this
this looks interesting with all the
boats
hmm
shipping is some middle school [ __ ]
oh no
[Music]
and they're brothers so [ __ ]
[Music]
ew
you can't go there i i know but i wish i
could
because that'd be neat
i don't think we're strong enough to do
this stuff yet i think um we should
probably go to the mountaintops first
get a bit stronger
and then uh we'll come back here before
we light the flame how about that
let's do that
we'll find some more stuff
[Music]
we gotta get stronger
get rivers of blood no
that's my answer
now
hello france
thanks for being here
thank you for the kind
[Music]
words we're doing
a soldier of god
rick playthrough
you not see my character
like come on bruh
jake only fans please
little do you guys know
little do you guys know
wait what's that
who's this
millicent
let's go
millicent helping us out here huh
didn't know that
that's cool
i'll get on millicent geez
oh
whoa
did she just do that
did you see that
i've never seen wow
holy [ __ ]
what weapon is that
oh that's her own
that's waterfowl
[Music]
i know she's melania's sister but i
guess that's a family thing
it's like a clone of her right
no i don't stream on twitch
let's not die here
oh she did it
it's not her daughter
it's not
it's like cologne
oh we're dead
that was not the time to tell us
that was that not the time to heal i
guess jeez it's crazy how that whole
fight just goes south
in like 10 seconds
yeah she's like a fragment of her or
something
from my understanding it's like clones
it's not melania's daughter
dude do people just say [ __ ] sometimes i
i don't know
oh yeah we got this
oh really
that's a good time to use that
it straight up tells us that it's not
her daughter so i don't know what you're
talking about
oh i thought it was out of it
i suck
gallery never says that
ever
[Music]
and he's annoying me too but can i have
his own opinion about stuff
she straight up says
millicent says i don't know what i am to
her
we found out later she's like a clone
from like certain item descriptions
i don't play
holy [ __ ] you are annoying oh my god
you're one of those people
into the head
kill us again
hold on i want to beat this guy
whoa
oh what the [ __ ]
he can just pull that out of nowhere bro
holy [ __ ]
it's getting one shot
not knowing if she is either a daughter
sister or offshoot
i mean that's what i thought but i'm
being told something different
hi tim so
i don't care like how much you've played
the game that doesn't like mean anything
i've platinum the game i've played it
seven times
that doesn't mean you understand what
you're being told
where'd she go
oh no i didn't do it
oh i did
pvp you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
that's it you're just an [ __ ]
just ban them please
the [ __ ] loser
we're talking about lore and he wants to
[ __ ] fight what an idiot
and dumbass
i barely rarely had someone in chat like
that so
at least that's rare
so
so
oh god i'm almost dead i didn't realize
stay over there
i mean should we have not banned that
guy
as soon as he said evp i got it mad and
wanted to get rid of him
oh my god
don't one shot me please
oh god almost dead
let's go millicent
good stuff
that's really cool
i did not know you could summon her for
that fight that's really cool
you know
ronnie's a doll so we don't know what
she looked like that's true
we should give him a second chance i
don't think so bro i really don't
i really don't
you're just gonna be a dick in the chat
and we just won't have you here
i was just disagreeing with what he was
saying and then he goes
fight me basically
fight me in game
no can you like he wasn't providing like
any
like why
is what you're saying true and he just
goes because i played the game seven
times
like that doesn't say anything
what are you talking about
pvp me dude i can prove it doesn't prove
anything forehead
whatever
whatever
hi muhammad
he meant you skipped the dialogue
which dialogue from who where at what
point
didn't answer any of that
i've done milliset's entire quest line
gallery makes clones of her
what's the deal with nicholas eclipse i
don't know
but i hope we get an eclipse in some dlc
that'd be sick
now that's just why i'm not a fan of
like pvp
i don't want to say everyone in pvp's
like that but bro
talking about lore
[Music]
oh
wait
well
forgot about yura
he is now shiburi
i think that's okay it's not too big
make chaos finally
we meet
the tarnished
who would be lord
oh my
why the long face
i fear that you were previously
acquainted with this vessel
well
that is most unfortunate
for he is dead
as for his
flesh wait
i thought i saw eyes in the back of it
i'm wrong
yeah i've used the full blade before
it's pretty good
it's really strong
why that armor set because we're doing a
soldier of god risk
playthrough
he talks so
quietly
[Music]
there's so many different ways they
could take the dlc that i have no idea
what they would do first
in her stead
if you are prepared to show resolve
this should be read through righteous
hardship pretty much finding out here
blame frenzy guy
good answer
descend into the depths far below the
earth
seek audience with the three fingers and
the flame of frenzy
if you inherit the flame of frenzy yeah
i don't think we see ronnie at all
in the renault fight we hear her and the
girl
can be spared
setting you on the righteous path of
lordship
the path of the lord of chaos
burn
the earth
that's a good theory conan and
incinerate
all that divide i think they were always
the same
may chaos take
the world
may chaos
take
the world
i have no idea what they're gonna do for
dlc chosen descendancy audience
oh we got to go down eat don't we
i don't care about this dude
i mean
he's all right he's a little [ __ ]
weird you know that is what it is
everyone's weird in this world huh
you know he's just doing his thing
he's just taken over the body of of uh
era
yeah we gotta go find millicent again
bird
that was yura taken over by shibriri
follower of
flame of frenzy
jake you international baby
what is what
ah
if they were always the same i wonder if
ronald had ever noticed sometimes
radagon had boobies
well
we can see that they can just morph into
one or another so i'm assuming merrick
that just didn't show herself when
like i have a theory that it was all a
part of america's plan she
she manifested ran a ratagon
to go along with her plan
that i made a video on
you guys are weird today
a little bit
i like it
man strong
be i don't i don't think there's a lot
of evidence for any of it when it comes
to ratagon america so we're just gonna
have to wait
nope
should be enough to level
we're weird every day
true
good point
you guys think i'm weird
great
dead
it's number eight
you want to hear a joke
no
melissa
what up girl how we doing
does radagon have multiple personality
disorder no
wait level
okay
you said know yourself
you goober
kind of like the game doesn't explain
every little detail it calls for a lot
of community input and i love seeing
different theories yeah me too that's
what they've always done in all of their
games you know
which is why i really enjoy them to
think we'd meet in such a place the hold
on i'll let her talk first
no
i know well enough who you are
and what i know is good enough for me
call upon me again
in battle no i don't think so philip
philippo
i think he goes along with everything
what kind of sucks not this doesn't suck
because
me saying this is not a bad thing where
um
the game has gone mainstream
uh way more players play this game than
every other from software game combined
so a lot of new players to the franchise
don't know
how the lore and the storytelling works
in these games
um and a lot of them are very frustrated
with people making theories because
usually these new players at least i've
noticed this
they will uh think one way and they
believe that there's no other
possibility for anything and if anyone
comes up with any other theory then they
get angry and frustrated and they tell
you that you're that they're wrong or
that you're wrong
um which isn't the [ __ ] point
but
a lot of people don't know that
so many new people don't know that so
it's like
[Music]
it it it just kind of is what it is with
with the game going mainstream which
which is great
but uh yeah it's definitely going to
lead to uh people getting uh angry
about certain theories or whatever
instead of just enjoying it for what it
is
uh there will definitely be an elden
ring too and there will be multiple dlcs
of this game before then absolutely
i would i would bet my entire life
savings on that
uh it's the fact that a large portion of
newcomers are quite entitled i agree i
think a lot of them are entitled i think
they're used to
a very like mainstream story that tells
you absolutely everything and holds your
hand
and
you know
it just is what it is now there's some
certain things in the game that we can
say say is concretely true
but
um
i would say most of it is just
uh us guessing us putting pieces
together
us doing our best
and
that's it
you can agree disagree whatever but you
know this doesn't matter
i'm searching for a fort to the north of
the ruins
i had the master of the fort
i do think before elden ring 2 we will
get um
like i think we'll get another
bloodborne right before them that is
where millennia will be found
the hailip tree is hidden somewhere in
these northern lands or another game
i'm searching for a fort to the north of
the room absolutely alexander 100
was given a medallion
that allowed him to visit the heilig
tree i was like that before i played
sakura in elden ring yeah i think that's
i think it's normal like it's fine
uh if some people just kind of don't get
it then it then it is what it is you
know
even i know as a newcomer don't doubt
anything unless something clearly
disproves it and also don't be a pee pee
poo poo head that's the best best way to
put that lord chunk
that's perfect
you can make your own theories you can
agree and disagree just don't be a pee
pee poopoo head who challenges me
to a pvp fight when
when you think i'm wrong about something
i'm searching for a fort to the
[Music]
yeah bloodborne on pc
at this point i think might do as well
as elden ring like for real bro like
actually would do as good as elden ring
maybe
there's a huge player base for for
bloodborne man
hey anthony thank you for becoming a
tarnished i appreciate that welcome dude
thank you so much
for becoming a member part of the
tarnish
good to have you here sir
guys did we do lieutenant
do we do everything for lieutenant
before i go any further
um she was way the heck over here
i could just check if she's in my
in my cubby
yep so
uh when we move through here lieutenant
should talk
like right here
do you hear me
it is
there we go
pretty cool right
uh i'll probably buy previous from
software games and try them out you guys
absolutely should like they're so
[ __ ] good all the games are good
maybe uh maybe not so much for uh dark
souls 2 but um you know it's good for
its own reason hey hey honestly go play
dark souls 2. i played the whole thing
and i didn't like it but hey
so there's a big following for it like
you might like it it's still a good game
it's still a good game but uh it's not a
it's not as good as the other ones in my
opinion but they're okay
how'd you start that voice line you got
to do uh lieutenant
antenna's quest
what's your favorite game i i would say
overall elden ring
bloodborne is a close second
uh then
probably dark souls 3
then securo
uh then dark souls won
i haven't played demon souls
unfortunately not all the way through
um but dark souls 2 would be at the
bottom absolutely
wait i don't want to do this
[ __ ] i forgot
no
oh god
oh we needed you for jar baron
can i just not kill him
[ __ ]
uh i might just let him kill me i'm
gonna i'm gonna let him kill me
yeah we're gonna have to not do that
because we need him for later
that's fine do you think dark souls 3
would have been better off pontiff had
been the final boss no i think dark
souls 3 is
when it comes to bosses i think is
almost perfect i i love dark souls 3 man
it's so good
i gained a lot of respect for you after
your elden ring save me video
well that's good i i opened up a little
bit
i was emotional that day
but i'm glad you liked it
it's it's been a very interesting
journey to get to this point very
interesting
the doll everyone was drooling over um
i mean you level up from a doll i don't
think everyone was like weird about it
so yeah
you really get unban or untimed out and
say you done
are you done
you [ __ ] weirdo
oh my god
it's very complicated and confusing ryan
we're doing our best
don't be a bozo
don't be a bozo
don't be a bozo we're still being a bozo
i've never heard that dialogue
so i can't say yes or no to that if you
heard that then
there you go
i've never heard that dialogue though
oh now he's gone
well
yikes
joe you did you just call me a
narcissist
will
interest i'm a narcissist i guess
oh you called him a narcissist okay
all right
hey taranator thank you very much
welcome to the tarnished it's good to
have you there's a
seed down there
why is my audio booking
porn get out of the way
thank you terenator welcome good to have
you
thank you very much
oh god this always scares me when do you
go up
can't you see it
or something
oh god
he's talking about the other guy all
right all right all right
i'll i'll calm down that guy made me mad
bro like i
it is what it is
what
jump
no it's not bugged i just couldn't see
where you're supposed to walk up there
usually you can see like stuff on the
ground and i couldn't see it
and it's not hard to make me mad the
thing is i get over it really fast
i'll be mad for like 10 seconds and then
i'll be like okay
but i've just never heard that dialogue
ever
my interpretation of what i think he's
talking about is gallery makes clones of
them so when he says like
they're the daughters i don't think
they're like actual
you know like melania was
had
had them like is their actual mother
does that even make sense
probably not
oh i went too far
there it is
he stinks it golf
listen if you guys go to my twitter i
hit a bomb yesterday i hit a bomb drive
yesterday you should go check it out
hello
[Music]
why is my audio booking
wait i wanna show you guys
i'm gonna die before i do though oh god
not a fan of fighting these things
it's a beyblade
hopefully they fall
can't see anything
heck are those
why's your fit so mid whoa
stop talking about your mom that way
dude
anyway you guys ready for this hold on
look at this
uh should i do the thing where i say go
follow me on twitter or whatever
i'm a content creator so i guess i
should plug my twitter constantly
i have like no [ __ ] like
i don't have any following on twitter
but
you hear that uh
that's me
boom
boom
little tight draw
boom
very nice
i just love that sound new driver
bang
damn bro
what's in here
reign of stars neat
let's go back down here
i love golf bro
you [ __ ] on reddit all the time but use
twitter i mean i wouldn't say i use
twitter
i post me golfing on twitter
also i [ __ ] on reddit because they
deserve it
i haven't had a bad altercation on
twitter yet
what is bowling lore
uh
holy [ __ ] what is that oh creative cloud
creative cloud guys
we got an update okay we're good sorry
is your driver upgrade
with smithing stops
that that sounds like you guys need to
go outside
i'm the chat prince i just realized you
guys aren't on the screen
usually chat's on the screen right why
is it not there
what happened
oh well
hey where's uh where's our boys at not
here
found them
wait no i didn't why are they not here
it should be right here
oh my god
the town i live in is discount yharnam
that sounds bad
oh
oh i forgot
yep
you can check the boss list in the
description
i need to update it though
[Music]
yeah we're doing enough damage
we can do this
wait oh
yeah oh yeah
not fair not fair not fair not fair not
fair
can i hit either one of them and do
damage
looks like
[Music]
i don't i don't want to talk about it
shut up
everyone shut up
we need to go back here anyway
where is corwin and gold meds
where do they go they should be up here
we we gotta upgrade don't we we really
do our our sword ain't cutting it right
now
oh i'm such a
that hurt that one hurt bro oh my god
i'm going to caleb because i deserve it
i fell off a cliff let's go find bosses
to kill out here or something
where's the dragon at
i'm gonna beat it up
isn't it over here
lord is humid this time of year
yes
yeah we killed commander neal
commander knee howl
i forget
where these guys are
stop
is there an entrance here
oh we already did this
did we
yep we're out
nope
oh i'm dead aren't i
we're back in caled because we need to
kill things to get runes and we need
upgrade materials
i don't know how we got out of there
alive let's go kill the dragon
i'm pretty sure he's over here
yep
there he is
didn't need to do that
yeah i call him commander o'neal
i don't know why
hi pascal how are you
i had to take care of the chicken
cool
not your head
dang it
oh [ __ ]
bruh
oh my god
let me
i straight up couldn't move at all
[Music]
oh we're struggling now aren't we oh boy
i remember you doing the puzzle for the
gold mask but i may have missed you
telling him that radagon is america we
did that we definitely did they should
be in the mountaintops now right
swear
yeah i got farted on bro
interesting
didn't even know that was like what it
does there
this might do more damage than me doing
the eye thing
i'm dead
heel man
okay
get the camera lock off
we're over it
as i continue to use camera lock rod
camera camera lock oh my god
i'm tripping
let me move please
i said please
oh yeah we got to kill the bell hunter
out here don't we
we might be strong enough for that now
his potential
i like this music too
he's dead let me swing huh
i don't know
oh come on bro
where is this spreading i can't even see
it there
do you have an opinion on which ending
is best for the lance
honestly was the world really that bad
before we came into it
you guys know what i mean was the world
really all that bad before we got here
and did everything
i think we
i think no matter what we do we we just
mess everything up man
that's that's what i think but
we'll see if we can upgrade
[Music]
i had to pick which ending was best
i don't know
i still don't have fives
where do we get uh a ball bearing for
smithing stone fives
and sixes
i'm glad you like them
tight show
now
uh-oh our moderator's leaving
it's a problem
okay let me look it up
i have a good one man
um
let's
stone
five
let's see some more ruins
really
you get it offer the smithing stone
miners bell bearing three
which is what we want
location in the zamor ruins
got it all right
we go
controller okay
most quest characters die we foil
reichard's plan we kill innocent radon
are taken from the tarnish and decide
the date of the future of the lands
between that's what we basically do yeah
i don't think anything that we do is
actually good
[Music]
however uh no one can really die
so that seems kind of bad
so i guess we fixed that problem
i mean if you really think about it
we're just kind of doing what people
tell us to do right we're not really
like
i guess we can make decisions on what we
do with that
but uh
yeah
okay let's see
not seeing an entrance to anything yet
ah
let me off torrent please thank you
may chaos
take
the world
nice
and we're out
oh should we give the
should we help the um jellyfish
you guys want to help the jellyfish
for now i'm gonna buy five we need five
more for the first upgrade
gunny five
poggers in the chat please pogba's in
the chat
we'll help the jellyfish
we need six more smithing sixes
could we come up with something that
youtube chat says because poggers is
twitch is a twitch thing
uh six
let's come up with a new
thing
we're better than that
we are better than that okay now we need
like 12 smithing stone sevens
if that's even possible i didn't look
moogers
freaky snoop
oh we don't even have sevens all right
where do i get sevens
the new catch phrases are you guys
already horny
i say that every stream now you're
you're right i really do
i really do
methane stone
[Music]
seven
let's see
we'll upgrade
[Music]
wellberry number four
location crumpling pharah missoula
dropped by the godskin duo uh we gotta
beat the godskins bruh
oh [ __ ] all right we can do that i think
we're good for now
let's try
and uh
beat moog again
so is our thing me just asking you if
you're horny
so instead of saying poggers i go you
horny yet chat
it it can be a pain good grief it can
388
okay
[Music]
that's a good amount we're still getting
hit though
now that's faster than i thought
[Music]
that worked
[Music]
i didn't
see much damage video here
1200 that's not bad
go back up back up back up
oh
[Music]
you find a pillar
i went right into that one
bro the range on that and it cracked
[Music]
not going in would work there it did not
it's doable now though
i shouldn't have talked
[Music]
dang
that was a mistake
big mistake speed man huge
massive mistakes
[Music]
gotta heal through that
that
he's gonna swing one more time
yep
okay two more times okay
[Music]
way to go in
that's unfortunate
we're gonna use our last deal here it's
gonna be it's just gonna be a battle
let's get it
[ __ ]
not a good start
really bad start
oh my god i have no health do we go for
the big one
[Music]
one more oh my god
i don't know how much health i have but
it's not a lot
you horny now
are you horny now
oh man how much can i check how much
health i have
how do i check my health
17
17 hp
yeah
totally planned
yes
yes i am
oh what a great game you know what a
great what a great time
to be here
imagine
all right
what's in here again
jake is all cheeked up here on a
wednesday afternoon it's true
you're just uh you're speaking facts
about that what's this dude raises
maximum hp stamina and equipment load
that well that's a [ __ ] no-brainer
the soldier of rick
does not yield
he does not die
this area is [ __ ] up
[Music]
why did they click you hear that
well i'm gonna let chat decide what
ending we picked so
before we get too far i'm still gonna do
it um but if chat wants me to do a
different ending
uh then we'll get nicholas we'll get
mickla's needle and use it
but if they want me to do this then i
will
[Music]
all hail rick
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we'll do millicent's quest line as
well
[Music]
see this is nice
i'm not ending stream we're going for a
long time today bro
i would say
i could probably stream for another like
four hours actually
close to it
i like the music here
what if they put that there because they
know you're just gonna die a whole bunch
of times between the [ __ ]
[Music]
all right
i'm putting a poll out
check it
does he make
does he make
it down in one try
yes or no
you guys think i make it down here in
one attempt
i'm pretty sure first time i did this i
died like 40 times trying to get down
here without dying
[Music]
blows up
just immediately no
just a bunch of no's
oh come on dude
all right
whatever y'all are haters
that wasn't sketchy at all
[Music]
i'm so sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
i wanted to
hold on
[Music]
ah
shut up chat
[Music]
that's what you get
rick no
god bless america
my pain is immeasurable and my day is
ruined well don't worry about it guys we
haven't released dust and death yet and
he's back
look guys he's back
there he is everything's fine now
nobody can actually die
[Music]
all right i really thought i'd get this
in one try i really did i thought i had
a pattern
i don't
[Music]
look
i'll do uh
[Music]
not that i'll do uh
i'll dab
i'll dab for him okay
i'll do a dab
dab
great job man okay
pay him
i paid him in a dab
[Music]
that's all he gets
holy shnikes
[Music]
it's like scoob
zoinks man
son of a
[Music]
[Music]
i'm not talking again until i get to the
bottom
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
please
hmm
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first try
not even hard first try
i'm the best
did i scare you with my voice
time to get yelled at
if you intend to claim the frenzied
flame
i ask that you cease are you horny yet
to be meddled with
it is chaos devouring life and thought
unending
however ruined this world has become
however mired in torment and despair
life endures
births continue
there is beauty in that
is there not
if you would become lord
do not deny this notion
please
leave the frenzied flame alone
i ask you
one more time
please
where's hayetta wait how do we get her
here
as one who's i don't remember to become
a lord
deny not the lives
the new births of this world
those who would are not fit to be called
lord
when the land they preside over is
lifeless
the comb is real
goodbye melina
um
give her enough grapes feed her horny
grapes where is she
i gave her one grape
one
where is she now though like where does
she go after uh being on the cliff
[Music]
she's at the bellum church
where's that
not this is it
that's earth
[Music]
purified ruins purified ruins
where's that
oh here
hey i found it look at that
that's crazy i was right on it
i kind of like not talking
i scare you guys
there's just a bunch of nerds around
here
magic user
now
no
sir i shat my s
why did that make me laugh
sir i pooped
cannon tarnished commentary no words at
all just noises exactly i was playing
the part
hey you guys said she's here what
yo where's she at though bro
dog
that dog
i bet she's right here
this ain't real
do
a grape
we need that
near the water west side
okay
near the water
west side
i thought that was her for a second
west side okay thanks
she's looking at the lobsters
she have a thing for lobsters
does she like lobsters
what's the lore behind hayetta looking
at lobsters
wait she can't even see dog hello
there's someone there
would you donate to any superior grapes
in your possession to me you know it i'm
on a pilgrimage in search of the distant
light and when i eat one of those grapes
i can feel the light in the back of my
eyes
here you go you're not like the others
who give me grapes are you
they rest their trembling hands upon me
howling wordlessly they gently stroke my
eyes that's weird fingers emaciated
yet still
they give me the grapes but you
see me
are you not concerned about the guys
touching you
okay okay
you are most kind indeed
may the blessing of the fingers be upon
you okay now where did she go
i almost hit the attack button for no
reason
uh if you did newcastle morn quest you
can't give her all the grapes
uh we did
[Music]
hey it's metal babe hi i need to make
you a mod hold on
he goes yo
moderator
immediate moderator
press one if you're jealous
i did kyle
now she should be northeast gate town
bridge head to the revengers shack to
fight edgar
the revenger for the next grape
[Music]
revengers shack
where is that
and thank you
mod
mod
immediate body
i'm gailing
69 that's a good number that's a good
number
okay you said
you said where
west lorena
okay
that's the four bell freeze
north west
here
nope
is joker 2 a thing
by the minor tree on the west side
uh here then
here
all the way to the left under the four
belfries thank you
so this one
[Music]
let's go this way
she's in the elden ring world thank you
that's great
that's east
i thought you said
waste
hey nobody translate what she's saying
you're gonna get a hate raid
on reddit
let's fight this guy
the cuckoo
all right who this baddie at
holy balls
balls
his name is balls
[Music]
these weakest balls
that's all i know about that
actually it's pronounced
that goat gets to live
he's a strong goat
[Music]
avoiding my attack so easily
rick is impressed
well how in the balls do i get up there
i don't know if i've been up there
before
how long do you stream for as much as i
want
[Music]
oh looks like i can just go around
do you hate reddit
um
no
i dislike certain parts of reddit
i have been up here before
i was tripping
i thought i might get a stagger on that
one
there we go
you're dead
this is the sweetheart
okay so
where's the break
where's the grape
asylum they even got above pretty it is
actually a reskinned asylum demon
true
clean
north
heading north
killing this guy
he died
north
so did i pass it
oh i passed the shack um
[Music]
well we need to kill that boss anyway
good job chat
you did all the work
is the new obi-wan kenobi show good
so you said it's in the trees right i'm
gonna check this really quick because i
don't
i'm gonna go down here
i'm just gonna go check it out
but i will be back
ooh sword dance it's lit
damn those some big gravestones bro
yes
no
most of you are saying yes
sword dance is sexy can i put it on this
see
i can talk to melania here
what does she say
adhd just going nuts right now there is
something i'd like to say okay mommy my
purpose was given to me by my mother
wait america
i act of my own volition
i have set my heart upon the world that
i would have
regardless
of my mother's designs
i won't allow anyone
to speak ill of that
not even you
i mean i wasn't gonna
but okay
whatever
oh i can't put it on it
that's okay
you call her mommy you don't
yeah melano
melon is hot i'll say it
melon is hot
is it like i think it's more accurate to
say that she's cute
man this is right here
okay
i dig it
report two grave wart three report three
nobody likes you
are we horny
negative conan
and of culture
sick vids thanks
do you guys feel like my persona on
stream matches the videos i make because
i don't think it does at all
in the videos i'm like normally super
serious
and in this i'm just like melon is hot
like are you surprised
did you expect me to be like vaati
what did i pick up from there i was i
was reading chat
video jake is not stream jake is not
apex jake is not winery jake through
i go to the wineries i get a little get
a little frisky
get a little frisky with it
because i knew you as a super serious
lore guy
yeah
i'm just having fun
making content bro
where are the big doors at
did i miss them over here
and i yell at kids in apex too
i blame kids for cheating is there a
hidden wall here
ah
[Music]
nobody likes you
wow a rune art sick i'm gonna use it
actually
uh i don't expect anyone to be like vati
not at all i know a lot of people like
that i'm surprised there's no mimic
cheese in this game
no but it makes your content that much
more appealing getting something
different depending on the topic
uh your vids are like professional and
on stream you're mowgers
yeah i get like there's a there's a way
to entertain people
uh through like the videos and there's a
different way to entertain through
stream like if i was just walking around
reading every item description in the
game i don't think you guys would like
that very much
that would probably be boring
right
watchdog
staff missed the door
hold the door
hold the door
is this different
sorry i'll stop
was that cringe
nice
if it was good
there's our big doors
hold the door
bhati is a good narrator that's all
he's just good info gatherer like off
here
uh i mean i don't i don't know how much
goes into vatti's
like how much he like does vadi edit his
own videos and stuff
or does he have an editor
because i do everything by myself
all right who we got in here
where's the snail
is he in here
i see you
thought he could hide from me
imagine
imagine hiding from me
my life changed like crazy i work all
the time do sip all the time but it's
been great so far glad to hear you're
doing great
oh it's stan hi stan
you all good bro nice good to hear good
to hear
we got all the mods here today let's go
we're only missing coal i think
if jen were here i would make her a mod
as well
i do have to message you that all the
time don't i metal i do
do you guys think being a content
creator is easy or hard
like if you had to guess
and if you are one what do you think
okay let's go to that shack
i play on pc
looking for shaq
oh
okay here we go
uh-oh i'm getting invaded
hard hard difficult stressing hard as
[ __ ]
[Music]
who's this
edgar
why is he mad at me what did i do
[Music]
or is he just shrouded in revenge
[Music]
imagine
rip
edgar
easy as [ __ ] duh
i will i will say that um
i would think having an editor would be
probably the best thing ever
editing takes
i would say
80 of the time to make a video
like recording it takes like 30 minutes
depending on the length
uh
getting all the footage and then editing
it together oh my god bro
it's takes it just takes so
long
okay now where do i give her my great
that sounded weird
editing takes five days when you only
have an ipad
yeah well i need to make it
dead miss me got in here that's cool um
i'll make more money medals so you can
be my editor because you did a great job
on that uh subnautica video
honey i need to make more money first
though
it takes a lot of time
bridge by town side of grace northeast
of gate town bridge
gate town that's here right
academy gate town
gate town bridge
north east of gate okay thank you
give me your grape
your shabriri grape
northwest
okay
hey there she is look at that
the prairie hello
there's someone there
no now they're casino bots
what the [ __ ] in search of the distant
life oh and when i eat one of those
grapes never ending i can feel the light
in the back of my eyes
give rape
many thanks to you
now i can feel the distant light once
more no i don't have netflix anymore so
i don't watch stranger things scrapes
really are
delectably tender and sweet they're
eyeballs
you're eating eyeballs
metal did you become a great rune
oh my god
thank you that's a little bit above the
tarnish thank you very much
welcome do you get a different color i
think you're still green or well you're
gonna be blue because you're a mod
oh god chad do we tell her
do we tell her
i guess i would have
i'd just go they're eyeballs
metal thank you very much
welcome to the great runes you're the
best
thank you
so i should tell her
is she gonna freak out dude there's a
lot of quest lines that i've seen one
time but never did myself i have to do
things to be able to remember her to
remember them
all right let's do it
no
that's not possible i think it
is room
yeah so those noises i heard were yeah
they're people
yeah i'm sorry
i yeah you might want to puke that back
up that's really weird that's really
concerning
i'm all right now yeah it's kind of
gross
you can puke if you want
here i'll wait here you can puke if you
want okay sorry you're right i apologize
you only did as i asked yeah i kind of
did
think no more of it
you okay i apologize
you only did as i asked i'll be fine
okay
so is she now down under
yeah
are you okay
i apologize i'll be fine
i don't think she's okay guys
[Music]
she should be at bellum church and wants
a fingerprint grape uh head to the
church ambition uh to be invaded by bike
search of
innovation where's that at
is that in this area as well
you have to get a grape from fighting
bike okay that's what we're gonna do
she's faking it no shot bro
rest and talk again all right we'll give
that a try why not why not why not let's
do it
i'm such a prankster yeah i didn't i
don't know why that prank didn't go over
well with her
she uh you know it's just eyeballs i
thought it'd be funny
north of church of vows okay thank
you is you over there
i've gleaned something very important
indeed thanks to you my audio keeps
poking the reason why it was eyes i had
to eat
the distant light
is far
and frail
so faint it can't be seen by the naked
eye but with everyone's eyes together it
appears
finally it all makes sense i'm certain
now
i will be a finger maiden ew who wants
to be a finger maiden i've gleaned
something very important indeed thanks
to you
i'm certain now
all right uh so north of the church of
vows yeah
so church of vows
you said it was in another church right
i'll just go here for now
finger me my maiden there we go
good job chat
[Music]
press one if you would bang every
character in this game
all of them
here's a better question
if you could bang every character in the
game
would you
but you would have to bang all of them
to bang even one of them
that make sense okay you said north i'm
going south sorry okay
all of you were saying one
okay
good talk
stan doesn't
i don't know why my audio is [ __ ] i
might have to restart my game
where am i going what am i doing here
you hear that
oh
no
that scared the [ __ ] out of me
no it's just a different tier of
membership sub zero
stop spamming one okay where am i going
what am i doing
do i need to go even further north
or from the grant start from the grand
lift go east
but really do be aware of madness start
from the grand lift and go east
okay
you will run into a village that is
plagued with madness
this magnus
madness
okay so this way
cringe
might have died
wow this is [ __ ] beautiful right here
oh my god
okay i'm going east going east
be prepared for madness build-up
uh-oh i'm scared now
cat there's nothing there
or do i have to go i probably throw up
there
rob
holy what
whoa whoa whoa
holy [ __ ]
this is just like bloodborne
oh don't look at it run
run
oh we made it we're the best
wait there's another tower
this is madness
where's that who do i kill
you
if it sees you it maddens you
i hate madden
hey a chest
owl of shabri
this is exactly like bloodhorn yeah oh
i'm dying
did i do it
wow that was scary holy [ __ ]
man there's so much of this game that
i'm learning every day and it's all
because of you chat thank you
now we can make more lore videos because
we know [ __ ]
is there an elden ring boss that you
can't beat up in real life
do you guys think that you could fist
fight against radon and win
almost died
hey where am i where am i going now
this looks kind of sus
easy
really
okay so mike's gonna be in here
i think is what you said
this game is low-key really scary
frenzy cookbook
you would kick radon's ass easy
there's a grace behind you
okay
let me go get that real quick
real quick yep thank you that's actually
really helpful
melania can get these hands
honestly melania would be easy if she
didn't uh
heal with her sword i think if it were a
fist fight
i could beat her up
not that i'd want to
well i just killed all those guys and
now i don't know
i should have done the thing
my rambling make any sense
we already did uh
that guy
whoa
kill me
all right
jabrie's whoa
i hear things that are scaring me
oh that's just a mausoleum okay
so what's going on around here what's
happening
hi rattlesnake
oh hello thought i killed you here we go
there's another one
oh my god
keep going up the hill
yes daddy
continuing continuing
there's gonna be another one in there
[Music]
oh that one's empty okay
it's jake i think i'm i think i'm horny
it's dj
as well
hey i'm just gonna keep moving
so this is where you get all the info
huh
gross flower
okay so
looks like you guys are telling me
there's a church around here
[Music]
tried to pick those up and missed every
single one of them
did i miss it
or do i have to go up the hill here now
really hard to look around
and
read chat
and look for stuff and then understand
chat
we gotta go up here i see
more
climb
hello ghosty i see the church now thank
you
ah lord vike it seems that you were no
lord after all
then where is he our true lord our lord
of frenzied flame we beg of you
incinerate all that divides and
distinguishes
ah
made chaos
take
the world
you guys think i could have been uh
could have been a voice actor
ah
make it oh let's take the world
there he is
like
rp walk toward each other he ruined it
poke
no healing
stupid idiot
fingerprint great
oh and his war sphere that's lit okay
thank you for the help chat
man we beat his butthole though bro i
mean god damn
love bike lawyer
was this his maiden
he's hot
wait what
bro she's hot
never mind
got a secret here though
that america yeah it is
he killed his maiden
what a forehead
what does this do
causes concoction to explode
would that explode me
weird okay
she's probably still warm
too dark of a joke
she looks like she just died like she
doesn't look
wow okay so now can i go down under
the [ __ ] is that
what is that on the ground
i think it's just a oh
wow okay
cry exploding it
looks like your mom
shut up all right we're going down under
i think i think we did everything we
need to do right
inspect chamber
frenzied flame description
which is weird because a bike roamed way
earlier than we did yeah he was one of
the tarnished right
like one of the early tarnished she's
not here
oh i have to give her the grape again
got it thank you
i thought we gave her the grape here
um
[Music]
which one was that
i'm forgetting where the church is
you need to go check on him as well
i'm tripping right now
bellum church
bellum highway probably uh close
or not
kabir corrupted him and he was closest
to elden lord oh my god
imagine
can i put this in like alphabetical
order of some kind
oh i don't have it
okay where is it
[Music]
i go there
[Music]
other side of gate and follow path to
the left bellam church can be found on
the north side of lorena
in lornea lakes
give her the balls
is it like here
let me go here real quick
i guess i didn't get the the grace
or i haven't ever been there
is it in there
there's a grace right there
oh okay i see
you want me to go to the gate that goes
over here
okay
i'm gonna make it daytime
just north of that gate okay thank you
someone said avoid the finger reader i
don't know why
i will
yeah there is a nice cap over here
let's do this first though let's get
hydra done
oh i thought i had been here i guess not
i must have yeeted right on by it huh
oh my god i'm so funny
let me do this real quick
i don't know someone said in chat so i
did
you want another eyeball oh hello
is that you over there uh-huh have you
ever heard of fingerprint grapes no but
i have one special grapes which only
grow on those who've been clasped by the
burnt fingers
i would truly love to try one really the
distant bite seems far closer than
before
but i can't sense a thing from the usual
grapes anymore that's crazy because i
have that grape you're talking about
to me
without one i don't know
i feel like i might go mad
what if i eat it right in front of her
all right let's give her the grape
oh
a fingerprint grape
tried and true what a wondrous thing
a fingerprint grape are we actually
close to 60 000 subs by the way
holy [ __ ]
how
how it sweet
thank you
i've composed myself again
may the blessing of the fingers be upon
you
oh she's tripping huh thank you i'm sure
i'll be a finger maiden okay now we can
go down under
i don't know she looks like she's
tripping balls
when she eats those eyeballs
she wouldn't see idiot okay all right
[Music]
hey
man she's fast
wow
[Music]
so you're here 500.
after divesting yourself of your
possessions
it will surely open
and the three fingers will welcome you
may the flame of chaos
find purchase within you
oh god okay go to the tour ahead
after divesting yourself of your it will
surely open
okay
let's take off our clothes
oh yeah
look at this man
it's time
bye kyle have a great day
how does she make it anywhere without
being able to see we'll never know
you can't open the door unless you strip
let's do this thing
[Music]
that looks like it hurt
no we can get rid of the flame of frenzy
of chat once if you guys want the flame
of frenzy ending we can do that
[Music]
i think we've done everything else tony
we'll let chat decide when the time
comes
oh well melania's gonna leave but we've
all seen that part a million times
stop spamming
stop spamming it doesn't help
it's just annoying
we've all seen that a million times
we've seen melania sacrifice herself to
the thingy
ow
that looks painful
[Music]
okay
she's still here
yep
the flame of chaos has nestled within
you
could you please rest your hand upon me
burn me with the flame what to make me
your maiden
hutch hyena
hawk could you please rest your hand
upon me
burn me with the flame
to make me your maiden
oh god
could we touch her
i'mma do it
oh
it burns
my eyes
my eyes
they're melting
my bad
thank you
why are you thanking me
i have touched them
the words of the three fingers
as your maiden
allow me to define them
all that there is came from the one
great
then came fractures
and births
and souls with a greater will made a
mistake
torment
despair
affliction every sin
every curse
every one born of the mistake
and so
what was borrowed
must be returned
melt it all away with the yellow chaos
flame oh my god
is one again
wow
those who gave me grapes
however
saying they wish they were never born
they come their lord
take their torment
despair their affliction
every sin
every curse
and melt it all away
as the lord of chaos
no more fractures
wait what the
are you good
huh
frenzied flame seal
flame frenzy
stone frenzy flamestone
um
[Music]
oh [ __ ] i forgot to put my clothes back
on
[Music]
well
i think she's dead
why does everything we do kill someone
i was too hot for oh god damn it
you
have inherited
the frenzied flame yeah i have
you are no longer fit no you're fat
journey together
ends here good and remember
should you rise as the lord of chaos i
might i will kill you no you won't
as sure as night follows day
such is my duty
for allowing you the strength of runes
goodbye
my companion goodbye
tauren
son of a [ __ ]
well
i really do ruin the life of every woman
i meet in this game i really do
they just die
alright then
i lost two maidens in five minutes
good job chat
it's all your fault
not my fault
it's your fault though
where's my
sword why don't i see it
those are albertos
oh there it is
let me put my clothes back on
uh yep
yep
let's get back this is not what i was
wearing
wrong shirt
right
is this what i've been wearing
yeah it is
well
chances of being laid zero percent you
can ruin my life too if you want
okay
three if you count like yeah it's true
uh she says she take she can take the
power of runes from us but she doesn't
so
it's cool
uh just do the skip to the halo tree
then wrong way warp the pharam and then
we can get rid of
you guys are funny okay so i think we
just got to continue now right
we did everything for alexander so we
should meet him at the dragon or the
fire giant fight
porn should be up here bro why are they
not
let's go check again
we didn't kill bach
for some reason
yes we got the frenzy seal we did
hot man
i wonder if i have more emote slots
we might
i need to check
i could make a pot emote
we saved bach before jake could kill him
okay dude
okay dude
all right there bucko
get this real quick
[Music]
since when is there snow in this game
i guess you haven't made it this far in
the game yet
okay if they're not up here why wouldn't
they be
yeah why is the gold mass in corwin not
up here
it's really confusing
that snails
okay bro
i didn't want to fall to my desk there
nice placement of rocks
yeah why why are corn and gold mass not
here did i just not do all of the
dialogue i needed to do over here
to this area it says they're not there
anymore young eater
box still there
yeah we we met them there
[Music]
i'm gonna have to go check it it doesn't
say they're still there but let's go see
we can we can see uh where they are over
there as well
they should definitely be there i don't
know why they're not though
is that the wrong bridge
is it really
can we see his eyes yes dude
rick looks awesome now
i swear it's that bridge
is it the wrong bridge
yeah because they're not there anymore
so
[Music]
i think it is
that's the wrong
what
oh my god i think you're right
it's the next bridge
oh my god they're way the hell over
there okay got it got it
son of a
okay let's try and beat these guys up i
got mowed
i roll
[Music]
i knew it i'm the best
yes sub-zero
how are you
oh he's just summoning another one
jake john
i rolled bro
oh god
[Music]
[Music]
i thought that would end it
one more
that's right
i'm the best
nobody
is stronger
than me
i am the soldier of god
thy name is rick
no idea why i picked a fight with that
guy
are you horny now chat
damn
he looks pretty right now
uh-oh
we are uh
sad ah
nice to see you never mind
i can't believe you've come all this way
been gripped by a terrifying thought the
rhythms and calculus of the master's
finger
betray a suspicion of the holism
does ronnie care if i have the flame of
frenzy inside of me i simply lost my
head
only
if the master were true to the golden
order
why would he think to breach this
forbidden mount of fire
i don't know
oh master
put my mind at ease
and dispel these fears of thoughts
he's realizing chat
to be your scribe he's realizing it it's
all fake
oh god do we give him do you guys want
me to give him this
the tonic of forgetfulness
i think we should
[Music]
it doesn't cancel all other endings
unless we uh we can get the other
endings back
no
no
i wonder if all dead people in the
chairs around the world are victims of
the dung eater
could be
you'll be stuck here for the rest of the
game
you can but he won't take it
really
if you give it to him now you can't
finish the quest okay i won't give it to
you
do you need something
i won't do it
you guys are seeing me
seem to be warning me uh big time here
so no
let's let's continue
should we go beat up the nobles with the
with the weird snail summons
oh i can uh also
yeah these aren't really gonna matter
but let's do them anyway
get dunked baby
jump off the edge there's a chest there
says the guy who didn't know there was
snow in the game
definitely going to believe that one
buddy
he'll fire giant
we we will get there we got to kill this
uh this dragon first actually
i always just run past this dragon
because at this point in the game i feel
like dragons are kind of overused and
they're all kind of the same fight
but might as well
we gotta do it
there's maidens down there
jumps immediately
[Music]
bruh i'm so i can't even see the dragon
let me heal torrent
[Music]
there you are
that's
just really unfortunate timing
[Music]
oh
[Music]
go torrent front
run baby nice
can't see what he's doing
[Music]
[Music]
really dude
[Music]
the only thing i like about the dragon
fights is the music
i think the music's really good
[Music]
for it
yes it's a dog
that's a big one
[Music]
isn't his name borealis is that how you
say his name
dude really like i'm running away almost
immediately
this fight can instantly shot you like
so quick
really i just walked
right through his wing
no double scream
okay
that was
does this guy not stagger
[Music]
i've been smacking his face
yeah midir was probably the best dragon
fight
possible
i mean i've been hit a bunch of times in
this run so
definitely not a no hit run
okay couldn't even see your wing
[Music]
dude don't kill me please please please
holy [ __ ]
come on man
no shot
[Music]
that's not good come on
he hasn't done that attack a single time
please
no way
i please
that [ __ ] dragon
like wow
like that fight can end
in a millisecond
wow
you you could have just hit his feet low
you could have just hit his feet one
time and you wouldn't have taken all
that damage and you would have almost
you wouldn't have almost not died lowell
oh my god really
no [ __ ]
your forehead
you could have just hit his little toes
he would have died
two levels
hmm one one
i need one
92
92 let's do that
[Music]
they like i feel i feel the same way
luke
i really do
i feel like all the enemies in the game
go crazy when they're low on health
that scared me i forgot that was there
okay
this is a cool cave i enjoy this cave
name
you laugh now but you didn't think to do
that during the fight did you
in the moment
you didn't do what i was doing when i
did my playthrough
in my playthrough i just hit his toes
and i didn't almost die
shut up
shut your mouth
[Music]
see you snail
see the other snail
oh god
oh god
nice
i lost 60k runes because of that yeah
oh we've had haters bro i just don't
give a [ __ ]
yeah these snails smell bad bro that's
that's my problem with them
[Music]
that's ost in the game baby
what a waste
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
owie
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
can we get the snail before killing both
of these guys
is the snail right here
i love how i got stuck in that that was
sick
[Music]
really
[Music]
i'm looking
[Music]
you guys are giving me
different answers here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
oh gosh [ __ ]
hey one down
[Music]
just beat him
you guys give great advice you know that
[Music]
[Music]
billy
[Music]
[Music]
oh i've rolled bro
[Music]
weird ass attacks
[Music]
this is gonna be tough boys
[Music]
i am just rolling the wrong direction
that's all i'm doing here it's just bad
bad i'm just bad
stop rolling please
i wow
[Music]
uh
[Music]
he just wouldn't stop
he just wouldn't stop
man i gotta go all the way back oh my
god
okay we can get it on this one i believe
summon i'll summon your mom
[Music]
howdy
where the [ __ ] did you come from
get out of the way don't stand right
there oh my god oh my god
they programmed that [ __ ] wolf to
back up right in the way
[Music]
oh my god dude their [ __ ] attacks are
so awkward
[Music]
that's what we like to see right there
i would have died if i got hit there
[Music]
got backed up into a corner
[Music]
fish
[Music]
what
in tarnation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
these [ __ ] guys bro
[Music]
hey i can get one hit in there
unfortunately
[Music]
[Music]
the
man i don't know when to [ __ ] attack
this guy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that's not good
[Music]
all right i don't even want to do this
one this one's just [ __ ] annoying
nope
takes too damn long
i can feel myself getting mad at that
fight already so i'm just gone
gone
nope
not putting sleep on nothing
i'm just leaving
we'll come back
not using summons
we already killed the dragon
it's a tactical retreat
perfect way to put it
that's the bell bearing we need to
upgrade our
sword
that's exactly what we wanted
you know what here's what i'm going to
do
we got a twig
nope never mind we're not doing that all
right
he's going to go get my rooney boys
i know where the cave is um
[Music]
7 500 huh
you can fight bike
evergale
or maybe is he not there after we did
the thingy
hi simon
have a good one
so he's still here huh
the different bike
that's
what a dodge holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
you bastard
he only gets the one though
[Music]
[Music]
nice
back it out back it out let him heal i'm
actually gonna heal
stagger city
didn't mean to do that one
stagger city
hurt that hurt a lot we're gonna back it
up
[Music]
get out of that one and boom
gg
[Music]
good stuff boys good stuff
easy peasy
we are moog champion out here is that
our new thing moog champ
we'll keep doing the your horny thing
obviously all right let's go
get a resting spot
and then go
in level
level our weapon
mode champ
knee heel pog
okay
let's do a bit of that
we are getting a lot done today we are
doing it we're doing the thing
we're doing it
upgrade time
i took you no matter it's all i had your
arm
uh
okay so i'm gonna need everything i'm
gonna need 12 sevens
i have zero
trying to keep your death sofia
you don't like that part i like that
part
bearing
purchase
didn't i get the seven
oh my god that's not it
did i offer the wrong one
wait what the heck
this weapon is not somber
heck is this sorry i'm looking at an
email we're good
i got the wrong one
[Music]
it says uh oh you get that in pharah
zulu
[Music]
oh
damn really [ __ ]
dude why are smithing stones so hard to
come across
i feel like i can find sombers way
[ __ ] easier than smithing
i guess you only need one
let's go get the mimics here i think
that would be funny
it's ancestral woods
let's go get the mimic here
let's have two godricks around or two uh
two ricks
that's not where i wanted to go um
oh i never went down there
okay
well we need to do it anyway
for ronnie's quest line
[Music]
you level [ __ ] it
three
what's your favorite christmas movie
christmas vacation
i think
fringe
theme that's so muggers
christmas story is good
i like christmas story
black flip blade
are we horny yet
you
kneel before rick
lowell
let's go and talk
i'm horny and i'm proud
yes greetings
uh oh
wait
greetings are you here
welcome back
we're still playing here we go
see if we can buy a ghost for
we have ghost wise
we've got a six
oh wait we have a five
we need a four
and beyond
for those graves
nope i was just tripping my balls off
right there for a second i guess i bet
uh there's actually a quest you can do
with the jellyfish
okay
so we have our mimics here upgraded a
bit
i'm a little salty about losing to the
godskins there so
i'm going back
i'm a little salty about it
i won't cap
we're going in though
it upgrades an upgrade
i'm pickle rick
[Music]
i'm pickle rick
what's that
oh okay
i'm pickle
oh rick
[Music]
hey my runes are still here let's go
stop fighting them
[Music]
he's fighting through the cave door
there we go
i dodged
i did
i'm annoyed with all of that happening
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
other rick i wouldn't go in there all
right
[Music]
[Music]
well that was way easier
[Music]
yeah there's three phases
the third one's a joke though
[Music]
please rick
other rick is dead
that's not good
[Music]
cool
that's not good
i'll take it though
[Music]
that seemed unfair
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
big hit
[Music]
leave me alone for two seconds please
[ __ ] you
[Music]
wow
[Music]
godskin swaddling cloth
we did it
3b
metal i murdered the snail murdered it
yeah many believe uh yeah we talked
about if you want my opinion on what
happened with the translations and
daniel and stuff go to the beginning of
yesterday's stream
that's all i gotta say about that
okay
looking good looking good family
family
okay so
church
board contender
now you can't have my pancakes
i wanted waffles anyway
no i don't watch fasters
hmm
waffles are better than pancakes
yeah i can have sausage
that's exactly why they're better
um we should find no we already talked
to millicent didn't we
we did okay
we should be able to find uh
alexander here
you should help us with the fire giant i
believe
yeah now i'm hungry way to go
uh we'll find all the death root
eventually uh
eew casinos
mods help
thanks metal
you're the
you're the best
and i ignore this guy he's extremely
difficult to kill and doesn't give you
anything and it's super annoying that he
doesn't give you anything
it was a giant hand
all right where do we summon alexander
at
you just in the boss room
or outside of it
wasn't it right there
there he is
alexander
warrior jar
let's do it buddy
well thank you territory i appreciate
that paranator excuse me
we have accomplished a lot here we are
at the fire giant oh wait i can't use
torrent oh god that's awful okay
we're gonna be fine alexander's gonna
die in five seconds and then i get back
on touring
let's get it
where's your foot at
nice alexander
[Music]
roly-poly
yeah why is it we can just like roll
through the plate
[Music]
alexander's really tanky huh
i think
because i used to summon the fire giant
has more health right
i'll summon other rick in stage two
can we get him to fall
that'd be great
i ditched my nose
nice
[Music]
let's go
it doesn't make his health go up really
i thought it did
yeah he died to radon so fast but maybe
he got way stronger from there
is he picked up the corpses from radon's
uh battlefield
[Music]
you guys notice that his armpit is an
ear
i imagine that hurt a lot
like a lot
it's legitimate feet worship isn't it
okay
okay boys
other rick fly free
i like bonk in his head
nice roll
get him guys
we should have just stabbed him
[Music]
[Music]
run
alexander got porch bro
i want to miss an opportunity to get a
couple oh god
all right i'll take it
now
holy [ __ ]
what's up dakota
give me your hands
i think other rick died
well that would have sucked
come on baby
close
one more
no
get him alexander
he must have no help
bruh
bruh
no
please don't kill me
we need to tickle him
i i for i agree with what you say
luke i think enemies in this game go
crazy when they're low on health 100
get some w's in the chat for alexander
what a legend
absolute legend
all right
so i'm pretty sure
before you ask are you horny now chet
are you entertained
yeah he just runs away i don't i'm not i
i think the aesthetic of that fight is
absolutely incredible
but i think uh
the fight itself is kind of mid
anyway
yeah we'll we'll find alexander any at
some point soon um
what else is there to do guys um
i'm pretty sure we can do dung eater
even after pharaoh missoula right
i'm i'm
very certain we can
like he'll stay down there
um
we gotta do ronnie that's right we have
to finish ronnie um so let's go down
under yeah we gotta do ronnie's [ __ ] so
let's go
we gotta go all the way down
oh i should have just
hit the thing down there but we're fine
let's go do ronnie
there's a church
[Music]
there is
it's not a church at the fire giant is
there
nope
haven't beaten a still yet
i kind of waited for ronnie's questline
to the end because i feel like
everyone's done it
but let's do it
speed up a ball
we started fiat
but we haven't gone to the deep roots
yet
blight is not insane now
yeah i would say ronnie's the most
popular ending right
i already got the mimics here
thanks for the subs
we're getting really close to 60k i
thought we'd get the 60k at the end of
the week it looks like we could get the
60k by tomorrow
i just haven't infused it yet
with anything
is ronnie good though i think that
depends on what you think
three
finger slayer blade baby hey over there
you're being a forehead
not even close
good job
he has four hands of course she's good
does that make her good
sure
why not i could have just rested i'm
filming
when i saw you give your dog belly rubs
for subs i was hooked i mean she gets
belly rubs like every
10 seconds by my entire family so she's
she's good
ronnie is the only good one in the game
[Music]
really
[Music]
hmm did they say that
let's what should we upgrade now
endurance or should i just keep
upgrading my health
yeah i think that's a very reasonable
explanation shadow i don't know if it's
100 true i just wouldn't know why else
there's just a crater
uh with starlight shards all around it
down to where her two fingers is
yeah should we do 60 we can only upgrade
one times this isn't that big of a deal
but
i think the only thing that i need to go
for now is just health right
yeah let's just do that
okay so now let's go back
um
[Music]
should we talk to
[Music]
i want is blide already in his uh his
thing here
i'm gonna go check
health and endurance
yeah i was thinking endurance as well
but we're reaching the end here i mean
what's our level now
yeah we're level that's level 100 right
there i would say we need like probably
level 120
to fight melania
without being there for five hours but
yeah
there he is
he's howling boys
are you horny now chad
oh it's me
[Music]
all right
i'm letting you guys choose
because i'm gonna make this be your
fault
[Music]
i'm gonna let this be your fault
but i started a poll
vote there
let him out
you don't know
you don't know
[Music]
oh none of you know
you're all saying yes
[Music]
i waited a little bit longer
[Music]
uh that's going to be uh 100 percent
i'm at the forlorn evergale
does he escape anyway all right
let's let our boy out
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know what came over oliji
but even if the odds are slim i know the
invader isn't him
now
ronnie can finally set the motion
the fight against i just don't want to
kill him
i'm going to see mr shirani now i don't
know what came over already but even if
the odds are slim
i need to check if my mysteries is safe
okay
let's go talk to eg
this half-wolf makes me buy
you guys are very interesting people
ah
you finally come
blithe told me everything
you've defeated general radan where's my
screen glitching the stars
the general was blighted by scarlet rot
and driven to
madness but not long ago he was hailed
as the mightiest demigod of them all
there is no parallel to your achievement
no too ladyrani's acute judgment it's
percentages not people
lady ronnie's fate once again still oh
that still doesn't add up to 100 percent
has opened weird
underground
where the fallen star struck klimgrave
smash your pass on blind
the precious treasure
of nokron
why is blight in the evergill i presume
you've spoken with blind
very well
that is something you should know i was
very disappointed in cyberpunk 2077
as a faithful follower
her very shadow
incapable yeah i haven't read berserk
but if lady ronnie you guys said berserk
is bad but why is it so popular
the shadow will go mad
transforming from a follower
into a horrid curse
but smash is his destiny
in such matters blythe's own thoughts
hold no weight
it pains me so
but he must be naturalized my my high
hopes
my hopes were super high for cyberpunk
uh and i was very much
very very much let down
all right
let's see ronnie
you said berserk is bad a bunch of
people in my chat the other day
and i was confused because i see
everyone talking about it
but i've never even heard of it before
before all the memes on twitter
isn't it an anime
maybe they were saying the anime was bad
and not the manga or whatever
ronnie ah
it was thee
not blythe it seemeth
even in my slumber i sensed it
it is in thy possession is it not why is
the anime bad compared to the manga like
what happened my thanks
finally all the pieces are in place
soon must i begin my journey
upon the dark i'm just talking about
what my chat said metal
but before i i don't know
i shall entrust thee with this
nice my thanks for thy sterling efforts
a strange gift perhaps but a rare sort
such as thee would welcome it i'm sure
i am certain now
fate steered us to our reunion it has no
ending this thank torrent too for his
part what do you mean it doesn't
on a journey okay
so now
he gonna be gone
if we uh is selling dead
did we kill this guy
we're not selling celibus
the author died but his team will
continue the manga based on his wishes
is that what i saw on twitter like
yesterday
their announcement or whatever
i don't know i haven't been following
them i don't like even know what's going
on
kill him now if you haven't yeah
they're making a new chapter that's what
i thought i saw
you can't just end you can't not in
something right
and he's still standing
i don't even think i'm talking yet well
well you took me at my word did you not
realize i was merely being polite
you i mean i gave him the uh i gave
ronnie the finger slayer blade just now
uh
i suppose you're here now
perhaps i'll give you something to do
i'd like you to find a woman called
nephili to administer a potion
even you can do that much can't you
yeah
good good
now i shall hand over the potion i'm
just going to give it to gideon
find nefari and ensure she drinks it
i expect clad tidings
and soon
i have no time for idle chitchat
the only thing i will hear from you is a
report of your tasks completion
are we understood this guy's such a dick
then off your truck
i have enough on my plate i have enough
on my me
i have no tying the only thing are we
and i have a knife
off you shot
hey man subscribed forever ago and love
your content
your personal video you did hit super
close to home and i hope you are doing
better keep up the good work bro dude
that's super nice for you to say and a
20 super chat with it thank you very
much i'm glad uh it seemed like that
video hit home with a lot of people so
that makes me very happy um well not
that other people have been in similar
situations but everything is better
we're all good life's great
everything's awesome but thank you very
much for the kind words i really really
appreciate that thank you
super nice of you
i noticed that my the video kind of lags
out whenever somebody subs or something
so
thank you man hearts in the chat we have
hearts
on youtube i don't even know parts in
the chat for uh
millennial falcons i really appreciate
it thank you very much
and all is well hope all is well with
you too
me oh yeah we got a we got a big fat
heart let's go
yeah arts in the chat thank you very
much
that's a pretty heart
i think you can just use like iphone
emojis
oh
audio
okay
so
we can go to the round table
all the hearts
all the hearts
all the hearts all the hearts
oh i should go do this
[ __ ] it
before we forget i forget about this guy
every time
that's a wicked
attack
[Music]
um
okay
he damn
yeah frost bleed build
yeah our community is kind of awesome
i'm not gonna cap on that
community is actually really cool
i do find it funny however that you guys
know that my most recent gideon video
right you know the ending's fake right
a lot of people miss that they're like
whoa is it real
no
cipher pattern is that
that a weapon
actual weapon
the indians fake the uh yeah the ending
of the video isn't real it's it's some
guy did it
i did it as a troll as a meme
where it's the dialogue where gideon's
like did you put your tarnish did you
put her in a jar
and fill it with your tarnished seed or
whatever
yeah that's not real
it's some guy who can do the uh the
voice acting really well
but everyone was like whoa really and
then there were a ton of people were
like no that's not real
yeah talking about her forearms okay
cypherpada what is this one of the
weapons originated from the two fingers
a formless sequence of ciphers comprised
comprise its blade
and has
and as such no shield can repel it
deals holy damage
his inscription appears to hang in the
air the language of light spoken by the
two fingers
is this
um
is this like a version of what's through
queen america at the end
i believed you i know
lot of people did
i had fun with that though
yeah let's go back what is happening
with my audio i kind of want to restart
my game real quick
or wait i should do this
okay either nothing's gonna happen or
the audio is gonna go crazy for a second
so everybody hold
okay
that seems fine
now it might go crazy
yup
the chat's back
yay
was that not there the whole time
well here we
go you guys are back yay
nice
[Music]
we're on the screen
you managed to return
you know what this means i think it's
caught up pretty close earth tree has
burned you
the fingers
remain still
shaken
by this turn of events
i might try a different font
for the chat on the screen i feel like
it's hard to read the fingers will again
but thousands
if not tens of thousands of moons must
first pass
no matter for me
but you
hey listen man none of you guys said
nothing
none of you guys said
okay goodbye
uh we gotta talk to gideon that's why
we're here nope the audio still bugs out
what's going on with that
it's kind of saucy if you ask me
you
what is it
uh yeah it's all your fault all your
fault chat is that portion what i think
it is bloody solidus
i suppose he's up to something again
yeah he is i won't interfere
you go ahead and do what you must
the round table has no code to speak of
but i ask you this
are you really going to do the bidding
of that twisted dolly botherer
oh
would you rather guys you know who my
biggest crush in this game is see if we
can't get one over on the bastard
and over
i'm gonna hand it over
good
i'll dispose of the potion myself
you go and see celina's but don't give
anything away dolly butter
as planned
despite knowing next to bloody nothing
he's still fired up his own ass he won't
suspect a thing
his inevitable display of arrogance my
biggest crush is
definitely in a fella
who do you think is the most evil
[ __ ] in this game gideon 100
gideon or
celebus
yeah i've told you that before
oh you
leave me be he's pathetic i know but i
i need to think i'm not saying psych i
think nephili is freaking good looking
dude ah you please he's pathetic now we
gotta go back and talk to gideon
yeah i think gideon's worse enceladus in
the long run
well what is it now
the valley's despair
you've already heard
indeed
it seemed the wealth harvard suspicions
so i had no further use for
i suspect that's just what the queen
wants i'm gonna restart my games of
ambition to incite the tarnished
wait where'd the chat go oh it's back
what is going on
let me restart my game really quick
holy [ __ ] we're almost 24 hours into
this play-through
let's be honest about his intentions
gideon does all this murderous stuff
behind everyone's back exactly bro
what's your screensaver
about to find out oh this is our list
that we should probably update
i mean i can hear it
uh this is my screensaver
just this
nothing crazy
i gotta update apex
[Music]
yeah i like it i think it's cool
just my logo
hi sophia
i mean roderick is a 10. the fellaini's
at a close nine i love how we're raiding
like fake
people
would watch you play apex nobody wants
to watch me play apex i'm not good i'm
not very good at apex
i wouldn't say i'm very good at a
[ __ ]
ring either but here we are
i think apex is one of the most watched
things on um
uh on twitch
yeah nafel is hot bro like she's jacked
ah you
please
let me be it's pathetic i know but i
i need to think
i heard from gideon so you know already
do you
right
bless it's true thank you
my father cast me out for indulging my
emotions
forgetting the mission
punishment for offing his pawns
father
mother
lord gideon pragmatic
i would have done anything i agree
to place him on the throne of belden
yeah i think nefel is like a type
the thing is like i'm into uh
like my type is like either
nephili or like the exact opposite of
her it's really weird
not the exact opposite but like i don't
know
every gamer in the world wants a hot hot
goth chick you know
so that's my type as well
i think i talked to gideon again right
no he doesn't give a [ __ ] anymore
oh my god have we done anything for
kenneth height
i don't think we have nope
he's just [ __ ] standing out there
still bro
oh god all right let's go
hey that's me i'm a hot goth chick
yeah but you're taken though
kenneth
grant me sucker
where'd he go
grant me sucker
[Music]
this all is going on a giant meteor
crashed into the earth like pretty close
to him and he's just over there [ __ ]
yelling is he there still
yep
there he is
all right um
wait maybe i already did it
oh yeah we will just annihilate
everything in that castle bro it won't
even be close
can i get down do i survive this fall no
i don't
should have gone to the other one i'm
going for it
i'm the best
he's vibing
he's vibing a little bit too hard if he
didn't react to a meteor
i haven't updated the list
i need to though we've done a lot today
ah i've been waiting for you with baited
breath
did you manage to recapture my fort
probably excellent news just i did okay
cool and the knights did to boot have a
good one terrinator my friend well done
indeed this i knew i was right to trust
you you have a crush on raven from teen
titans
yes
um i also had a crush on sam from danny
phantom
you're one of the most uninteresting
people in this game bro all right let's
go over here
he was sleeping
i find kenneth to be so uninteresting
what are the benefits of killing radon
he's a great rune
uh
he's uh
he wants to die
that's a good reason i think
[Music]
he wants an honorable death he doesn't
want to die but he wants an honorable
death
why is he not here
that's cringe did i not at dude can we
just not do kenneth hyatt are you guys
gonna get mad if we don't do kenneth
height
why do i try to do that wow i am amazing
okay
honestly doctor is nothing more than a
good freak
i'm mad
okay
execute him i'll do that
not doing kenneth means no to philly
yeah you're right
you're right okay
okay
okay
i just hate kenneth
[Music]
lord
don't make me laugh
i didn't get all this dialogue
would you like to and i see bright thing
yes i would like to enter your service
sir very well i knew i saw something
i see hey that's got to be everything
right
yep okay
i'll do anything for nafeli that's just
facts that's just true
he's gonna get dlc at least his dialogue
suggests it
all right i'd be fine with that
just don't find his side of the quest
line to be very uh
very interesting
i like the value though
what though
i'm surprised they're all still fighting
three
three
ah
you is it
i suppose you must have seen it by now
yes
the sorry state of my fault
or indeed it is a foul fate for a land
to be without a ruler
one must be found
i hope for dlc that's it awful godric
i don't care what it is but i i want it
for the proper lineage to take the reins
of limgrave
i'm sorry to have lifted your hopes
but i have sound society to raise you to
knighthood as things stand
the great kenneth height is used his
sincerest apology but now
i must begin yeah that's how i feel too
sofia it just feels like unfinished but
maybe there's more to it later on
i must begin my search post haste
for a true and stalwart lord of the
proper lineage to take the reigns of
limgrave so nafeli yeah i must think
you're a true okay so do i just go talk
to philly now
[Music]
to announce such tragedy yeah that's
awesome
no i don't know he once told me that if
he became elder lord
he would never allow the downtrodden to
be cheated ever again well he lied was
he simply lying to me yeah he was he was
no
no no
how could i say that
father has always given me his guidance
and now
i've lost it
pretty sure we got that
yep we have it give the stormhawk king
is that ash
i can smell the ancient storm in it
my thanks
i'll gladly take it
you're welcome i'm
not like roderick
i don't feel the presence of spirits
let alone see them
still
this ash
it reminds me of my first hulk
thank
you
it reminds me of my first hawk in this
ash
i can smell the ancient storm
it reminds me of my first heart
oh
you're really cute okay where did she go
now
he doesn't go straight to godric's
throne does she
i didn't want to go there
stop we're not shipping nothing
[Music]
sounds like she did own hawks
getting off near says we do a little bit
of trolling in the village
we kind of did
if she's not here yet
what do we uh
what do we do
do i talk to kenneth again
first
queen of thighs
[Music]
oh past the time
doesn't kenneth
i don't think so hold on let me let me
see
her father is big daddy godfrey i know
oh since i killed morgan already
okay
i must begin for a true
kenneth
look out
whoa that after swing
was uh
close
[Music]
you had to do was kill morgot okay
kenneth don't give a [ __ ]
would we be able to see her
can't see
the belly
he's a beast too apparently
oh there she is okay cool
oh they're both here i love it
i mean come on chad like she's hot
you really do be hot it's been some time
i must thank you i talked to you like 10
minutes ago
i told father i would be with him no
longer
i remembered the vow i took when i first
became a warrior so many moons ago
this land is much like the one from
which i hail
i will call upon the storm
to drive away the foulness that has
settled on the winds
again
i am nafely liu
warrior
some call me by the title of lady
but i remain the same woman underneath
though i have now abandoned my former
guidance
i cannot express how much you've helped
me
nice
should you become elden lord
i would gladly lighten your burden let's
go
we are a beast
what up kenneth ah
nice to see you after so long literally
talked to you five minutes
ago yes
good
ah quite
i have indeed selected a new ruler
lady nafelli is strong and just yeah she
is worthy of the burden of limb graves
lineage
such is the sincere opinion of i can it
height no less
for the time being i share command of
the castle with my lady
but i plan on returning to my fort
afterwards
at which time i can fulfill my own
promise
by raising you to the glory of
knighthood i hope it is just as
wonderful as you imagine
farewell fellow warrior
i will remain to summon the storm
but your guidance and your fight
surely lie elsewhere
why is chad disappearing
for the time being i share command at
which time i'm raising you to i hope it
is just that's it i will remain but your
guidance and your fight
surely elsewhere okay
got caught for whatever
whatever
okay oh we killed gostok he's a forehead
okay um
noticing something inquested ray lucario
celia
let's get your side
secret ending i don't know about that
what if the philly is a child if godfrey
that means the sister of godric
what if nafelli is a child of godfrey
that means she's a sister of godric no
she is the child of godfrey
technically
i mean she's your mommy
uh
i don't think that's true
oh we're grinding i'm debating right now
if uh i should end stream because it's
pretty much it's almost three o'clock
we have been grinding today it's been a
long stream i'm getting kind of tired
i think we'll come back to it
i think this is a good place to end the
stream
yeah
yeah four and a half hours is pretty
long boy stream okay
boys and girls
i'm punching the face we did a lot today
we did a ton bro in in four and a half
hours
we did a lot so but
we're gonna end it there
we'll be back
tomorrow go follow all the stuff if you
want
subscribe we're almost at 60 000
subscribers which is actually kind of
blowing my [ __ ] mind my goal is to
get to 100k by the end of the year which
seems very possible but
hey we'll see man so thank you for all
the support
thanks for being here you guys are
awesome
uh
follow me on twitter i'm trying to grow
my twitter because i literally don't
know how
i don't know how to get a following on
twitter i have no idea
so
i'm just gonna plug it
it's in the description go check it out
i'd appreciate it other than that
thanks for being here
we will be back
uh soon i don't think i'm gonna be
streaming tomorrow
but potentially the next day um i want
to get a video out uh by this weekend by
friday or saturday and i think it's a
pretty good one so
be on the lookout for that
it's gonna be lit
other than that i think that's
everything
you all have a great rest of your day
peace love
and i'll see you all soon